[Applaudissements]
c'est une des séquences préférées de
valérie bella le programme précédemment
dans l'inspecteur derrick
après avoir résolu une enquête en cinq
ans l'inspecteur derrick a décidé de
s'accorder un repos bien mérité adieu
mon gaudérique et après avoir passé un
été de folie à saint tropez
l'inspecteur derrick est de retour pour
de nouvelles aventures
[Musique]
c'est nous c'est des grosses alors chez
marc boules de gerard une bonne surprise
j'arrive juste de saint tropez c'est et
une dark arrêt la cour ces photos sur
facebook tu y es tu connais l'autre
connard de une guerre sur salut connard
dis moi tu jamais sur facebook
je t'envoie des messages sur messenger
et macache ma femme guy à je te disais
ma femme a ouvert mon facebook et elle
est tombée sur des messages à caractère
j'étais obligé de fermer mon compte
leicester tu t'es fait gauler assieds
toi raconte moi ça rouillard et sartec
l'un perd un taf facebook d'eric et tu
m'as toujours pas ajouter vos plats tu
la fermes ok bon écoute eric je peux
plus voir sa gueule je vais vous laisser
aller saluons potes à la prochaine ouais
ça lui ça lui connaît à bientôt
non c'est les water la sortie c'est par
là au fait en rasta femmes est me gossin
manquerez pas bon urbaine kale là je
vais te montrer mes photos de vacances
ça c'est moi en train de jouer du djembé
à sa part attend ça c'est moi a créé de
me faire dorer les couilles à quai sur
ce trou dunn et si tout cela
ouais là chômage préfère pas m'a rappelé
mes dires il ya pas moyen quoi commenté
trop beau laisse moi te regarder de plus
près un ton visage hilare et ma vie
c'est ouf qu'est ce que c'est que ce
talend merch à manger des poireaux
combat serré dans du jus d'huître ou
quoi lol
elle était presque aussi bonne que ta
femme si tu sais de quoi tu parles
derrick je viens d'aller sur ta page
facebook et tu ne m'as toujours pas
ajouter 1 alors que ami avec emmerich
je connais m riche de la coupe sar mais
arrête un peu des salamalecs chez même
pas qui c'est henrich siens et hu lui
même sur instagram tu peux lui demander
oui les [ __ ] a été une photo hier
hashtag autriche non mais tu vois un
stade gros kiff et pour moi hashtag rien
du tout hein pas à la règle et tu veux
quoi à la fin c'est simple où tu m'as
joutes où ces hashtag démission voilà
chômage sur ma vie obligé d'ajouter
gurgen en ami a à ce propos d'eric il
faudrait que tu penses être calmée avec
ton facebook
pourquoi me calmer parce que tant - des
messages à ma femme à une heure du matin
oui et a links et les photos de ma serre
et arrête de match et ma femme sur tille
heures ok je suis grillé vous m'avez
tous gonflé je me barre 15 jours en
vacances à midi mienne revenir je
tombais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]